hi reject nation Greg Alva here Tony
Tony Gill you could follow him on
whatever's in the description box at the
moment
Roger easy I want to tell you guys
where's one game that Tony and I when we
meet up we play this game online every
time boy do we suck at it there are
people that are people that is all about
the fun of dying halo Infinite brand-new
trailer here I want to give a pitch of
the day shout out to JT the man from
Hawaii JT I got a Thank You bud because
I went on movie fights recently and I
don't want to do too much I was spoiler
but I did amazing I did pretty good on
movie fights and a lot of what I use as
arguments I actually ran by JT before I
went on the live segment and he was a
great person to bounce off of so JT I
did not thank you during the actual
livestream I'm sorry for that but so I
want to thank you here right now you are
an awesome support of our channel love
you do do you have our infinite love
there brought a full circle related UJ
all right O's headphones and on iPhones
on one too whoa 60 frames
a little too clear for my taste
[Music]
huh Wow look at the deer can he kill the
deer in this game I speak that like
old-school walkie-talkies invested
futuristic aim
[Music]
time travel it's going on
[Music]
the seduction here
[Music]
it's like we're watching Planet of the
Apes I know
[Music]
Wow
you
Stargate
[Music]
good old American Master Chief Phil the
first to like the classic she goes much
but I gotta say I'm still really excited
that's good teeth all right nice I love
that trailer because it starts off as
like this Wonder and amazement and
looking at the environment and then the
last 25 seconds becomes like this
patriotic Master Chief moment the
soldier returns do you know what's going
on in this trailer I have no idea what's
going on really I didn't get nothing
from this trailer of what's gonna happen
it's just an exciting tease for a return
to halo what I am hoping for what they
[ __ ] up with the last time the
split-screen okay I took that [ __ ] away
Halo 5 so like if me and you wanted to
play on same console bring that back
another thing was it looked a lot like
how halo 1 2 & 3 used to look yeah I
think halo 4 & 5 they were really bright
and like colorful this one kind of gives
you more of that grittier look at it had
in the first couple of halos yeah yeah
most simple landscapes to towards like
the online play then it was getting into
the story yeah I'm gonna be honest I
wasn't so excited about the last story
mode for the game so I didn't play it as
much as I thought I would I feel like
people have been wanting halo to kind of
go back to the originals yeah this gives
that vibe that nostalgic vibe for it
usually when you bring back old things
to a game it just feels like they don't
really do much but now that they've been
trying to advance it so much throughout
these last couple games it feels good
like we're gonna get a halo 2 halo 2 and
halo 3 were my favorite I went back to
the common opinion I do like that they
added in sprinting and like four and
five and I'm pretty sure they're gonna
do that for six but other than that four
and five they just try to add too many
things for this one go back to standards
you know try to keep him more of a
stealthier game yeah yeah just bring
back the old stuff man like it seems
like why would you want that but that's
exactly what I wanted a halo I feel like
that's a common thing I hear a lot of
people say especially the split-screen
one like the split screen is amazing I
think people want the dumbest thing they
could have ever done especially because
I think halos more popular for its
online gameplay than it is it's like
people love the story I know there's a
lot of people are very invested in the
story I think there's more people who
actually played the online and actually
played the story yeah so you take away
the split-screen that's a really big
disappointment biggest problems like
whenever you have a friend over now you
gotta wait until they're done so you get
your turn so even if they can make the
split screen look better than they used
to
that'd be cool but I could go back to
the old split screen it would be
perfectly fine with it and the armor to
looks like old school Master Chief that
looked badass
wondering like I know they were trying
to add all the new gear that you could
set up and stuff to make it more
customizable but like really I just want
like the old halo outfit I want the old
Halo vehicles I got to release halo just
the same with like Call of Duty did with
like infinite infinity war just all the
newer games that I make like advanced
warfare and stuff like that they try to
add too many new things and you just
didn't feel like Halo to me anymore so
stand up I'm ready for this one I think
this one's gonna bring us back to that
no magic that Xbox used to have amen to
that sister hey guys you excited for
halo again I know some people haven't
been too thrilled with Halo lately but
this seems to be getting a lot of buzz
she's looking good you guys can't
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification about the subscribe
buttons are kind of broken and you could
check us out on patreon full-length TV
show reactions weekly Q&A is Yatta Yatta
Yatta follow Tony on social media if
you've made it to the end of this video
comments what I said right here
Jehovah's Witness
death to everyone